carolyn fairburne director general of
the cbi which has said today that nine
in ten people will need new skills by
2030 to support the future economy
costing some 13 billion pounds
a year carolyn morning to you before we
we talk about uh this uh specific call
that you've made today
i just wonder what you think about what
we're seeing right now across the
country we've got
liverpool already in tier three northern
ireland in national lockdown wales
heading that way potentially greater
manchester
are we heading for a national lockdown
again via stealth
well i sincerely hope not ian i mean
these are
really crushing blows for the businesses
in those uh
areas where they have done so much to
make their businesses
coveted secure and made all sorts of
investments but you know
business we're not epidemiologists you
know we we
we will um of course uh go with
government judgment on this but the
absolutely crucial thing
is that the financial support packages
are in place and
there's real clarity around the trigger
points and neither of those
two things are working well enough at
the moment there is still too much
confusion
around the financial support i think the
cbi we think that tier three support
that does need to be more through local
authorities tier two support
um is not strong enough um and there are
opportunities there
and we do need clarity over the exit
strategy and what those trigger points
are
so real concern um in business
communities across the country i would
say today
carolyn i don't know whether you uh
heard what chris fletcher from the
greater manchester chamber of commerce
was saying to me just now but i mean one
of the things that uh he was uh
suggesting is that his members are
really confused if they go into tier
three
how long they will remain that way
because obviously that has a bearing on
their ability to
ride through the crisis and obviously
they'll be trying to conserve cash
as well this is an incredibly important
point because decisions that you take
around
around your staff around your cash cash
will be
you know running out the door at a
frightening rate at the moment and
timing is everything
and we we do word um the government and
and local leaders working together and
that's the other thing
it is very very damaging to see such
conflicts and confusion between
political leaders
but it would be very helpful to have
trigger points you know what are the
points at which uh regions come out of
lockdown
again and what is the appropriate
financial support around
around the time when they're in so
confusion i think is really damaging to
confidence
and really damaging to to businesses
ability to survive
so yes i think those trigger points
become critical
does the government need to be
publishing specific uh advice for local
authorities on that
well i think that they do and i would
really urge them to get around the table
with
uh with business we have seen that um
work very well during many parts of the
pandemic
in creating the right support packages
and guidelines
we need that again now it does feel as
though we have fragmented
as a as a country in terms of uh
politics um
and and and the relationship with
business communities
we we offer our support to government to
try and get these trigger points
uh in the right place of course
businesses will continue to put health
first they will continue
to protect their employees and customers
as they have all the way through
but communication consensus and unity
remain absolutely vital through this
now separately karen you've got this big
report out today on skills you're
calling for the apprenticeship levy to
be replaced by a flexible skills and
training levy what would the key
differences be
yes so this is a really important call
we've got today we've we've of course
got
got covered accelerating the changes in
the labor market and
with unemployment rising the importance
of
giving people opportunities to retrain
we think that 21 million people will
need new digital skills by 2030 to give
you an example
the apprentice levy apprenticeship levy
is a failed
experiment the idea is very good a ring
fence three billion pounds
that businesses are paying towards uh
training but the trouble is
it is so narrow it is not being used
properly and apprenticeships are
actually
falling and not rising so we are saying
broaden this levy out
make it usable for a much broader range
of training through lifetime learning in
particular
and we will help to get um this um this
very very important
uh opportunity for our nation to reskill
uh millions of people literally
uh to to help our economy succeed now
elsewhere carrying the government's
launched this new advertising campaign
today aimed at businesses saying time is
running out i mean
that would be greeted with hollow
laughter by a lot of your members given
that uh you've been urging the
government to do a deal
well i i mean this is no time to give up
on a deal and 71 trade associations put
a call
out over the weekend they represented
seven million
employees across the country saying the
benefits of a deal
are so great tariff-free a smooth
customs operations
and the fact that the northern ireland
protocol this incredibly important
protocol for peace and free trade in
northern ireland
none of these things can happen without
a deal and it really is about jobs
at a point in time where every single
job
counts so this is not a time to give up
businesses
of course they will prepare the cbi is
helping members
businesses to prepare across the country
we're investing very heavily in that
but there is so little time and this
really is a moment
both sides are still talking it's a call
to both sides
get that deal and i think we'll see
investment rise in this country we will
see
a a a bounce in our economy from this
very
uh challenging uh place and jobs will be
protected
who's better prepared for uh brexit
right now carolyn the government or
businesses
oh well i i i think preparations are
um as people have done as much as they
can but honestly there is one in five
business
hasn't prepared half of businesses um
have gone backwards in their
preparations
we are in the middle of a global
pandemic brexit was knocked off the
front page of every board agenda
in the country so we can't expect
businesses to be fully prepared and i
think frankly
the same is also true of government
now we will do all we can and frankly
even if there's a deal
there will be very important changes and
we are letting our
our members and businesses know to
prepare for those but honestly
and i think that the massive
responsibility is on negotiators on both
sides to get a deal
this really is jobs and livelihoods at
stake on both sides of the channel